si bien el número de personas que
protestan Y esa grupo de movilizaciones
que antes veíamos surgir en diferentes
partes no solamente de Teherán sino de
muchas ciudades se ha ido disminuyendo
las protestas siguen especialmente en
universidades o en barrios concretos de
algunas ciudades estas protestas siguen
dándose especialmente en el día sábado
que es el día que la población ha
escogido que es el comienzo de la semana
y es el día que han escogido para
protestar pero también se espera por
ejemplo que este miércoles hayan grandes
movilizaciones por qué Porque se cumplen
los 40 días del fallecimiento de maxa
Mini esa joven curda de 22 años que
murió después de haber sido capturada
por la policía la moral cuando estaba de
visita entera en el islam Chita esa es
una fecha muy importante porque ese día
la familia vuelve a reunirse para
recordar a su fallecido y con ellos la
comunidad Así que se espera que no
solamente lo acompañen en el resto sino
especialmente en el kurdistán iraní
donde se han dado algunas de las
protestas más importantes en todas estas
semanas haya habido decenas de personas
detenidas también muertas pero también
siguen habiendo no solamente protestas
sino paros de los comercios en muchas de
las ciudades de esta región del país y
también es importante destacar que en
estas cinco semanas muchas aspectos de
la sociedad han ido cambiando si bien el
sector comercial todavía no se anima a
salir a esas protestas no están muchos
de ellos de acuerdo con el gobierno o
con el estado sin embargo no quieren por
la situación económica dice que
solamente se van a unir si saben que van
a ganar algo si lo que hemos visto es
como las mujeres han ganado espacio para
andar en la calle sin el velo vemos
especialmente enterar muchísimas mujeres
sin ese velo y ya no solamente caído
sino muchas veces ni siquiera existe en
el cuello esa bufanda que tienen que
usar obligatoriamente las mujeres en
Irán